Ahora que sabemos un poco sobre la multiplicación
de números positivos y negativos, pensemos en
cómo podemos dividirlos. Lo que veremos es una
metodología muy similar: si ambos son positivos
obtendremos un resultado positivo, si uno es
negativo, pero no ambos, obtendremos un resultado
negativo; si ambos son negativos se cancelarán y
obtendremos un resultado positivo. Pero hagámoslo,
los invito a pausar este video e intentarlo por
ustedes mismos, y luego veamos si obtuvimos la
misma respuesta. De modo que tenemos 8 ÷ -2. Si
dijéramos 8 ÷ 2 eso sería igual a 4 positivo,
pero dado que exactamente uno de estos dos
números es negativo, este de aquí, el resultado
va a ser negativo, así que 8 ÷ -2 es igual a -4.
Ahora, -16 / 4 positivo. Seamos cuidadosos aquí,
si dijéramos 16 positivo dividido entre 4 positivo
eso sería igual a 4, pero debido a que exactamente
uno de estos dos números es negativo, entonces
obtendremos un resultado negativo. Ahora tenemos
-30 ÷ -5. Si dijéramos 30 ÷ 5 obtendríamos un
6 positivo, y como tengo un negativo dividido
entre un negativo, los negativos se cancelan, por
lo que mi respuesta seguirá siendo 6 positivo;
e incluso podría escribir un signo positivo aquí,
no tenemos que hacerlo pero este es un 6 positivo.
Un número negativo dividido entre otro número
negativo, al igual que un negativo multiplicado
por un negativo, nos dará un resultado positivo.
18 / 2, y esta es una pregunta un poco capciosa,
esto es lo que sabíamos hacer incluso antes de que
habláramos de números negativos. Este es un número
positivo dividido entre otro número positivo,
de lo cual vamos a obtener un número positivo,
entonces eso será igual a 9 positivo. Ahora
empecemos a hacer cosas interesantes. Aquí
hay una especie de problema compuesto: tenemos
multiplicación y división, para empezar por la
manera en que está escrito vamos a multiplicar
el numerador. Y si no están familiarizados con
este pequeño símbolo de punto es sólo otra forma
de escribir la multiplicación. Podríamos haber
escrito una x aquí pero veremos en álgebra que
el punto se vuelve mucho más común, porque no
queremos confundir el símbolo de la multiplicación
con la letra x que se usa mucho en álgebra,
por eso se usa el punto con mucha frecuencia.
Así que en el numerador nos dicen -7 • 3,
y tomaremos este producto para dividirlo
entre -1, 7 positivo por 3 es igual a 2,
pero dado que exactamente uno de estos dos es
negativo, esto va a ser igual a -21, así que
tenemos -21 / -1, dividimos -21 / -1. Un número
negativo dividido entre otro negativo va a ser
igual a un número positivo, así que esto va a ser
igual a 21 positivo. Déjenme escribir todas estas
cosas. Si dividimos un número positivo entre un
negativo eso va a ser igual a un número negativo,
si dividimos un número negativo entre uno
positivo eso va a ser igual a un número negativo,
si dividimos un número negativo entre otro
negativo eso va a ser igual a un número positivo,
y obviamente un número positivo dividido entre
otro positivo también va a ser igual a un número
positivo. Ahora hagamos este último que tenemos
aquí. En realidad todo esto es una multiplicación,
pero es interesante porque estamos multiplicando
tres cosas, podríamos ir de izquierda a derecha.
Primero multipliquemos (-2 x -7), (-2 x -7),
ambos son negativos, y los negativos se cancelan,
por lo que esto que tenemos aquí es igual
a 14 positivo. Entonces vamos a multiplicar
14 positivo por este -1. Ahora tenemos un
número positivo multiplicado por 1 negativo,
exactamente uno de ellos es negativo, así que
esta será una respuesta negativa, va a ser
igual a -14. Ahora déjenme dar un par de ejemplos
más. Podríamos decir que este tipo de problemas
tiene truco. ¿Qué pasaría si tuviéramos 0 / -5?
Bueno, esto es menos 0/5, entonces 0 dividido
entre cualquier cosa que no sea 0 simplemente
va a ser igual a 0. Pero ¿y si fuera al revés?,
¿qué pasa si decimos -5 / 0? Bueno, no sabemos qué
sucede cuando dividimos las cosas entre 0, no lo
hemos definido. Hay argumentos para conceptualizar
esto de muchas formas, por lo que tradicionalmente
decimos que no está definido, no hemos definido
qué sucede cuando algo se divide entre 0,
y de manera similar, incluso cuando tenemos 0
dividido entre 0, esto todavía es indefinido.